هل
التونسيين اللي بتساءلوا هالمزال امل يمكن
ان نعطيهم املا في المستقبل في تونس
تونسي لازم يكون مربوط بما صار بعد ثوره
قبل ثوره تونسيه منذ 12 سنه تونس الان في
فتره بناء ديمقراطي ديمقراطياتها بالطريقه
التي ولها تكاليف بطريقه ومصاريف وطريق
البناء الديمقراطيسه بالطريقه
تقدم وتاخر وتوقف
اجمالا لما نحلل على مستوى السنوات
والعشرات السنوات ان شاء الله احنا في
طريق همم الصحيح وفي تونس هناك طبقه من
اعلى راس من اعلى تراس من في جميع
المجالات في جميع المجلات
والعديد من المجالات وهذه الطبقه
خاصه في الثانويه وفي فتره هذا البناء
زادت في القوه وزادت في الثقافه عليهم
النخبه عن الشباب همم
هناك ارقام رسميا وهناك
دراسات خارجيه تقول انه هناك ضغوطات على
الماليه العموميه وضغوطات في السيوله
ومشاكل الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وهذا لا
يمكن الانكار ولكن الامل لما بلد عنده هذه
المبادئ وعنده وهذه النخبه وعنده هذا
الشباب ما شاء الله في تونس وبرا من تونس
وانا بعرف منهم الكثير همم عندنا هذه
الخيرات البشريه وهي القيام هلا باذن الله
تعالى متفائل على اعلى يونس والامل موجود
بقوه ان شاء الله اتمنى ان تونس بالطبعا
تكون فيها على الخلافه يعني همم تكون
منصات جهويه كبيره همم يعني همم في الصحه
وفي التعليم وفي وفي الماليه اتمنى ان
تستثمر اكثر في خيراتها وتاريخها
وحضاراتها كفالاتها وفي الفلاحه وفي سياحه
وغيرها في المعادي ال- ال- التاريخ الكبير
اللي عندها
واتمنى له همم تونس
احط كذلك التكنولوجيا راقي في مجال
الاقباله كفي مجال الصناعي وتكون رائده في
هذا المجال واتمنى كذلك ان تونس ان شاء
الله تكون هي اكثر من البوابه انها منصه
منصه لافريقيا بحكم القرابه
الافريقيه بحكم الجغرافيه
الثقافيه وبحكم التكلفه بحكم كذلك معركه
رجال التونسيين بالاسواق الافريقيه واللي
ممكن تساعد الدول العربيه
في هذه بعض التصور
تمنح الفرصه لكل هذه العقليات المتطوره
والمتعلمين في تونس من اجل ان يكون الاداء
واضح لا ان يكون الخلاف السياسي سببا في
ازاحه من يعلم لصالح من لا يعلم